this is new
hi everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play the SCP
containment breach
markiplier mod which I'm sure is gonna
be just fantastic
I mean someone brought this to my
attention that someone had made a
marklar mod recipe containment breach
and I was like rip brutally okay so
we're gonna give this a try wonder what
I wonder 1 I don't know I better start
from the intro sequences and just see
what happens because that music is so
lovely
I can't even begin to imagine how great
the rest of the game must be totally
respectful to make oh I'm going to enjoy
this I think maybe just a little bit boy
howdy
do I love dubstep I don't but that
something's going funky with that audio
quality and I wish this would load a lot
faster because I would like to get away
from this that is awful
oh man ok please please yes please ok
thank goodness man that was rough ok
we're off to a great start on behalf of
markiplier incorporated in our staff
blah blah blah d 9 3 4 1 ok hello hello
I'm not crazy I'm just trapped in a cell
by myself we're totally not crazy oh hi
ok ok set a dead space mask on you and
some dead space armor there don't try
anything oh I won't try anything it's
just me markiplier in my own place it
seems to be locked ok
oh shut up Wade that's not way either
I'm just I'm I'm at a loss I'm at a loss
for words here I don't even know how to
begin to explain oh hi you've got a
markiplier logo on you
it's just so weird hey look it's me it's
like they just pasted random bits of me
everywhere and what lovely music ha ha
ha no way hang on I got a gig nah I
can't handle it I can't I can't deal
with this I can't deal with this this is
just so weird I can't deal with any of
this I'm ha ha oh God I have nothing to
say about this at all this is totally
awesome totally professionally made and
my goodness
Oh aye me I'm guessing this is just
disturbing in a whole different level
than the normal SCP containment breach
because I mean this is thought that
someone went through all the trouble to
try to get let me read this maybe
there's just slap you just slapped
markiplier all over it and just barbed
wire markiplier wite-out something
markiplier okay I don't know I don't
know I don't even know wait a minute
okay I thought I thought some other
things might have markiplier splattered
all over it I don't know I don't know
hi I'll get to you in a second why I
don't know any of this am I gonna see a
little mustache out of the corner of my
eye when I flit around I wonder what I
wonder what 173 or me rather is gonna
say when he comes close to me I'm just
so perturbed by all of this
oh look it's me and me oh this is lovely
am I gonna hear the but ghost thing do I
have a thing about the putt ghosts in
here
oh hello it's dead body hello dead body
no but ghosts in here
okie dokie moving forward
hey look I just noticed in the blinky
icon it's me
and in the Ronnie icon it's me hey
seriously just slapped me all over the
place I I love it I loved every minute
of this I love everything about this
this is like this is this is the most
amazing thing I've ever played in my
life look it's still me I'm still there
apparently I'm radical Larry everyone
now knows that I am the old man and I'm
horribly old but I love every minute it
is hello okay this is the downstairs
area so am i down there is that what's
going on here am i down there am i down
there
it's a weirdest question I have to ask I
am down there
Jaime oh god that's so weird
you're so weird hi it's me
I cannot go down there I'm swear this is
just completely disturbing on a whole
nother level I don't even understand any
of this
what the hell I don't want any part of
that
stop with the poof's you're pooping
everywhere oh look oh wait it's the UH
it's the thingamabob er this is high
enough oh yeah it's okay
so we got a high enough card to get into
here I want to see what's whoops here
markiplier TV up here okay no thank you
now as I kept an open eye candy I don't
want any of this I don't want it I want
to go home you know and not look at
myself in the mirror ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever I'm gonna summon me when
I go in here hi hello hello hi me oh god
what is that oh oh no okay no how about
nope nope nope nope nope
good God shut up me and playing that
song God good God I'm out of here I'm
out of here this is so wrong it's so
wrong everything about is so wrong
anomalous duck help me out and why does
my vision keep flip-flopping over to the
other way he's still behind me I know
this hello yes poof it poops every time
the doors open oh look it's my room I'm
gonna have to contain myself eventually
but first I need to get myself a better
keycard so I'm wondering what changes
they made the ones are uh with 106 yes
thank you okay - uh the UH the machine
whatever it's called I don't even
remember what SCP number it is you'd
think I would considering I played this
so much hello it will explore it will
explode what will explode what are you
gonna make explode what is poofing stop
pooping hello let's see here nope I need
higher security clearance am i oh
oh god it's good god this guy needs to
fix the audio on this because there's
definitely something going wrong okay I
want to look at this I want to look at
this guy just to see what happens
because is this me
I bet it's me hi me Wow Wow God is oh so
wrong oh no no no no no no oh just kill
me kill me get it over with
I don't I don't even wanna I don't even
water I don't wanna I don't wanna I
wanna it's kind of murder ready oh I see
you want the camera when you get a cup
or oh it's good eyes coming where is he
where'd he go pretty go where is he
did he get stuck on the door is he gonna
get me he's gonna get me I'm gonna get
me I'm gonna get me I'm getting ah
this is so weird I can't take this
it's so weird everything about it is so
weird
whoa hi what I don't want any I don't go
away please go away please
I can't tell if I should be if I should
you know think oh they did a good job on
putting me in the game work oh this is
just so horrible I don't even know what
[ __ ] oh oh I want to go home I don't
want to be here I don't want to be here
Wow it's something that might jump
things get me I don't know is that they
got a I fell to the floor I've done I
can't take this yeah I can't do it I'm
done okay if you want to play this bod
for yourself you can check the link in
the description below but I highly just
right I don't recommend it at all I'll
take it's not good but it's just so
weird
no there you go there you have it okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
ah
Wow
mother
yeah
more about this